is violence an effective
method of resistance so the framework
that I would propose is
that Dr King mentioned that peace is not
the
absence of violence it's the presence of
justice and so occupation and apartheid
are violent even in their most
benevolent
manifestations the default of occupation
is that it is unjustified the default of
apartheid is that it is unjustified and
it must be dealt with the default of
resistance to occupation and apartheid
is that it is Justified but there can be
transgressions even in resisting
occupation and apartheid right and and I
come to this from an Islamic perspective
my moral framework is
Islam the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him was outraged when he
saw a woman or a child that was dead
from the other side the side of his
persecutors and so yes you know we have
a saying as Muslims that they are not
our teachers our oppressors are not our
teachers but the concept of resistance
to
occupation it is morally Justified it is
justified by international law and any
occupied people have the right to defend
themselves we talk about Israel's right
to defend itself Israel is the occupier
any occupied people by international law
have the right to defend
themselves uh and any occupation is
unjustified and illegal and so that's
where I start from that's the point that
I come to this with I think that the
problem is is that the Palestinians are
told find better ways to resist and then
they are
demonized when they try to find any
other way to resist you know if you go
back a few years ago you had the great
return March people in Gaza marched to
the wall in what was one of the most
inspiring protests or
demonstrations that I had ever seen
March to the wall nonviolent
protest and snipers took out their legs
AP actually
documented that Israeli snipers had KNE
counts where you had an Israeli soldier
that would say I took out 45 knees they
actually had a register a scroll of knee
counts and so you have all these kids in
Gaza walking around without legs now
because they were targeted by snipers
when they marched to the wall we're told
to find methods of non-violent
resistance but when we boycott when we
launch you know boycotts around the
world in response to this transgression
in response to this ongoing oppression
that the world powers have shown either
the inability or the unwillingness to
reign in we're told that that's
anti-semitic even though it is based on
the South African method of bringing an
end to the apartheid regime there so uh
don't respond with violence don't
respond
non-violently don't protest uh don't try
to use people power in the face of
global impotence at the political level
instead let's just keep talking about
the two St solution and while talking
about the two-state solution if you were
to look at a
map under every single Israeli
regime conservative or liberal whatever
it is the settlements have expanded more
Palestinian land has disappeared more
Palestinians have been dispossessed more
Palestinians have been killed and so we
have these little pieces of land that
keep on
shrinking and Jerusalem keeps
disappearing and there's aggression
whether Palestinians are resisting or
not but then we're told why can't you
people just pursue peace why can't you
just believe in a better way all along
we're hearing Israeli ministers become
far more radical and uh open about their
intentions to wipe us off the face of
the Earth and that is actually their
policy it's not just slogans it's not
Fringe elements actual Israeli ministers
starting from the Prime Minister himself
who has executed a policy of the removal
of all Palestinian lands and Palestinian
lives and then we're told peace peace
peace peace and it is awfully ugly when
you use the language of peace to
suffocate the work of Justice you know
Dr Martin Luther King Jr one of his
early sermons was something along the
lines of when peace is obnoxious when
peace is obnoxious it was in the
1950s around the Montgomery uh bus
boycott and he talked about how this
obsession with the language of peace is
usually used to try to
uh keep people in status quo and make
them complacent with their miserable
situation that has been the story of the
Palestinian people that they've been
told that if you do things differently
then you will find peace but everything
the Palestinians have tried inside and
outside has been met with repression the
most violent forms of it there in Gaza
and Beyond and so look I I start from
the place of wanting to see peace I want
to see a situation in which no innocent
people lose their
lives but we have to analyze the
situation with some justice with some
fairness what would any group of people
do in the situation that doesn't mean
that you hope for hell that means that
you analyze the existing circumstances
of Hell which was life in Gaza even
before October 7th that said you did
talk about wild L du and
dignity and you mentioned
transgressions so there is places where
violence can go too far absolutely so
violence again the point is is that you
you ask yourself why we've been silent
about the violence all of this time and
you know what when people say well what
about this what about that my response
is this what I would love to see is
effective International bodies of
Justice being able to reign in any party
that has committed an act of aggression
or committed an act of Injustice and
hold them accountable any reasonable
human being would say yeah you know what
there should be effective International
bodies that can reign in parties that
can't be reigned in domestically that
could stop the violence that could
assign blame properly and then have
methods of accountability the problem is
is that Israel has been made Invincible
in The Intern AAL Arena because of the
United States and then we wonder why
there's such a rise in global
anti-American sentiment it's not because
of American Freedom it's because America
is directly participating the United
States government is directly
participating in the worst genocide that
we have ever seen in our lives right
playing out on
screen you know on social media and we
can't do anything about it so I think
that the point is that we need those
International bodies we need methods of
effective accountability and I would
love to see blame properly assigned and
anyone that kills any innocent human
being take into account anyone that is
guilty of a war crime take into account
we have to ask ourselves why is it that
Israel has violated over 63 United
Nations resolutions has expanded its
occupation has killed over 600
Palestinians before October 7th why is
it that Israel cannot be h held
accountable and so when you talk about
you know words that get thrown around um
you know that that are used to justify
violence against more innocent
people you know when I'm asked about uh
terrorism is it only terrorism if it's a
non-state actor if someone's sitting
inside a room you know of suits and can
press a button and terrorize thousand
thousand of people and murder innocent
people with no
consequences how is that not terrorism
so if terrorism is only to be assigned
to non-state actors then it's a word
without function in fact it's a word
that justifies more terror that has then
reigned upon innocent populations we
have to have moral consistency children
should not be killed non-combatant
should not be targeted we can all agree
upon that why aren't there proper
investigative bodies and then proper
International bodies of accountability
then that can execute their findings in
a way that makes the world a better
place in a way that actually brings
about more peace and so you know I think
this is where we're at right now
and this is the frustration and this is
the the place that the Palestinians have
been left so to you violence becomes
terrorism when women and children
non-combatants are killed no matter who
is doing the killing
absolutely